sabemos que seguro que es una
corporación que opera a nivel de
subsidiarias prácticamente en todos los
países del mundo entonces tendríamos que
analizar diferentes situaciones como la
existencia de acuerdos para ejecución de
sentencias o reconocimientos de medidas
cautelares en esos países
la presencia efectiva de activos de
chevron en esos países porque en muchos
casos no tienen más que empresas
subsidiarias son utilizadas como para
cascarón para otras actividades pero que
en realidad no tienen ningún tipo de
activo en mi negocio los paraísos
fiscales especialmente entonces había
que hacer un trabajo muy minucioso para
identificar cuáles son los países que
ofrecían mejores posibilidades entre
esos se identificó a argentina brasil y
canadá también teníamos bienes en
colombia venezuela de algunos países
europeos que siguen bajo análisis y que
bueno esperando contar algún momento con
los recursos para iniciar o continuar
los procesos que ya se haya iniciado en
esos países pensamos hacerlo por el
momento bueno tuvimos una experiencia en
argentina que en principio fue muy
satisfactoria cuando conseguimos en
primera instancia un embargo total de
los activos de los bienes de chevron en
ese país
ese embargo fue ratificado en segunda
instancia por la corte de apelaciones
pero la sorpresa viene cuando llegamos a
la corte suprema y el gobierno argentino
estaba buscando un socio inversionista
para trabajar en los de los campos de
yacimientos no convencionales en la
provincia de neuquén en el sur
y fue entonces que cerró llegó y le
ofreció al gobierno tres mil millones de
dólares para esta inversión a cambio de
que evidentemente el gobierno ofrezca
garantías para que esta inversión no
vaya a ser embargada por los
ecuatorianos que teníamos una orden
judicial en ese país
en otras palabras le estaba diciendo
aquí te ponemos el dinero pero tú tienes
que levantarnos del embargo y
prácticamente como una orden venida
desde los altos directivos de la
corporación chevron eso fue lo que
sucedió en pos del interés nacional
argentina decidió levantar el embargo a
nivel de corte suprema y fue así cuando
llegaron a la corte de canadá en canadá
la historia bien un poco al revés esto
era como un antecedente de por qué
llegamos lo que habíamos identificado
algunos países canadá era uno de estos
canadá
fue identificado tanto por la presencia
de activos de chevron como por la
confiabilidad e independencia que se ve
en sus cortes
en un inicio esto empezó al revés que en
argentina nosotros perdimos en primera
instancia porque una corte dijo que esta
sentencia no podía ser reconocida en
canadá porque el juicio de los
ecuatorianos no tenía ninguna
vinculación prácticamente con la
provincia
ni con una compañía que lo en canadá
apelamos en segunda instancia fue
ratificada prácticamente en la misma
decisión pero luego la corte suprema nos
dio la razón dijo que los ecuatorianos
teníamos el derecho de presentar este
reclamo
para el reconocimiento de la sentencia
en una primera instancia y que la
disponibilidad de los bienes para ser
ejecutados es decir para la
disponibilidad de los bienes es decir
con canadá para satisfacer una deuda de
serón corporation sería un tema que se
tendría que discutir posteriormente y el
proceso fue reenviado otra vez la
primera instancia es bueno en primera
instancia por segunda ocasión nos
reconocieron nuestra capacidad de seguir
adelante con este proceso pero el
proceso fue nuevamente archivado bueno
se ordenó su archivo nuevamente
argumentando que los bienes de ese
abroncaron canadá no estarían
disponibles para satisfacer una deuda
con una deuda de la compañía de ser aun
corporation